Now that we've understood
the satisfiability problem,
we're ready to tackle
the Cook-Levin theorem.
Remember that we have to turn any
problem in NP into an instance of SAT.
So it's natural to start with the thing
that we know all problems in NP
have in common.
There's a non-deterministic machine
that decides them in polynomial time.
That's the definition, after all.
Therefore, let L be an arbitrary
language in NP, and
let M be a non-deterministic
Turing machine that decides L
in time at most p(n),
where, p is a polynomial.
In accepting computation, or
sequence of configurations for
the machine M, can be represented
in a tableau like this one here.
Each configuration in a sequence
is represented by a row.
Where we have one column for the state,
one column for the head position,
and columns for the values of
the first p event squares of the tape.
Note that no other squares can be
written to because there just isn't time
to move the head that far
in only p event steps.
Of course, the first row must
represent the initial configuration.
And the last one must be in
an accepting state in order for
the overall computation to be accepted.
Note that it's possible that the machine
will enter an accepting state before
step P event, but we can just
stipulate that when this happens,
all the rest of the rows in
the table have the same values.
This is like having the accept
state always transition to itself.
The Cook-Levin theorem then,
consists of arguing that the existence
of an accepting computation is
equivalent to being able to satisfy
a CNF formula that captures all
the rules for filling out this table.